The last decade has been pretty great for
science fiction films.
But while not every brilliant recent sci-fi
flick is worth owning and revisiting time
and time again, some definitely are.
Here are few modern classics that are so fun,
engaging, and compelling that they're totally
worth re-exploring over and over for years
to come.
Moon
Directed by Duncan Jones, the amazing movie
Moon takes place in pretty much one location,
and for the most part, it focuses on just
one actor, making the haunting end-result
all the more brilliant.
The story follows astronaut Sam Bell, played
by Sam Rockwell, who lives all alone on the
moon, mining the dusty satellite for fuel.
Bell's only company is a creepy robot named
GERTY, but that all changes when Bell discovers
a second astronaut …who looks just like
him.
Naturally, this discovery causes both doppelgängers
to question their own existence.
A smart, intriguing film with a small budget
but big ideas, the mysteries of Moon never
grow old, largely thanks to its charismatic
leading man.
Mad Max: Fury Road
The pinnacle of George Miller's career, Fury
Road is two adrenaline-laced hours of incredible
stunt work, breathtaking cinematography, and
badass warrior women riding through the desert
in big rigs and on motorcycles.
It's essentially one long, incredible chase
scene, with some of the most amazing set pieces
ever put on the big screen.
There's the epic sandstorm sequence, the death-defying
climax involving bad guys dropping in and
out of the action on massive poles ... and
dozens more instantly iconic moments that
deserve to be witnessed again and again, including,
of course, The Doof Warrior, wielding his
flame-throwing guitar.
Attack the Block
This charming British thriller follows a gang
of South London street toughs who find themselves
in the middle of an alien invasion.
Surrounded by freakish ape creatures with
lion-like teeth, the teens decide to press
pause on their criminal careers and take on
the extraterrestrials, using everything from
baseball bats to firecrackers to defeat their
otherworldly foes.
Attack the Block is a crowd-pleasing gem that
expertly mixes carnage and comedy.
"Is it safe?"
"No?
Okay.
Good luck."
On top of that, we genuinely come to care
about our heroes, especially Moses, the leader
of the group who's played by none other than
future Star Wars phenom John Boyega.
The Martian
Based on the bestselling novel of the same
name, The Martian stars Matt Damon as Mark
Watney, an American astronaut accidentally
abandoned on Mars.
Left to fend for himself, Watney is determined
to stay alive until help arrives.
But how is one mere Earthling supposed to
survive the cold indifference of the red planet?
It's exciting to watch Watney puzzle his way
out of one problem after another, whether
it's communicating with NASA or growing the
first Martian potatoes.
The film is so fun to revisit because it's
a rare, sincere love letter to human achievement.
If nothing else, The Martian proves that watching
people who are good at their jobs can be addictive.
"I'm gonna have to science the s--- out of
this."
Inception
A truly groundbreaking sci-fi film, Christopher
Nolan's Inception wowed audiences and critics
alike with its mind-bending visuals and brilliantly
layered action scenes.
The story moves with the speed of a runaway
train, following a group of dream thieves
as they pull off the ultimate heist.
The movie is full of twists and turns, so
with every viewing, there's an opportunity
to analyze a new detail or catch some fresh
clue.
"You never really remember the beginning of
a dream, do you?
You always end up right in the middle of what's
going on."
"I guess, yeah."
"So how did we end up here?"
As a result, the movie has spawned countless
fan theories, proving that when it comes to
rewatchability, Inception is a dream come
true.
Looper
You knew this one was coming.
If you're in the mood for more mind-bending
fun, it's always a safe bet to relive the
past and revisit Rian Johnson's Looper.
This time-travel thriller follows Joseph Gordon-Levitt
as Joe, a hitman who works for the mob in
2044.
His job is to execute victims sent back in
time from 2074, but things get a bit complicated
when the gangsters send back his older self,
played by Bruce Willis.
In addition to some breathtaking action scenes,
the movie also grapples with weighty issues
like the cyclical nature of violence and features
Joseph Gordon-Levitt sporting custom facial
prosthetics and contact lenses to pull off
some impressive "Young Bruce Willis" cosplay
— even if he does kinda look a little more
like a young Alec Baldwin.
It's got everything you need for the perfect
repeat viewing experience.
Edge of Tomorrow
If there was ever a movie meant to be re-lived
over and over again, it's 2014's Edge of Tomorrow.
Kind of like Groundhog Day with guns, this
military thriller follows a cowardly major
played by Tom Cruise who keeps experiencing
the same day over and over again.
Too bad the day in question involves a massive
alien invasion, and he only gets to start
it over after he's been violently killed.
Of course, this freaky form of eternal life
has its advantages.
The fun here comes from watching Cruise adjusting
each new day to the dangers at hand, and slowly
becoming a genuine war hero.
And while Cruise's character might get tired
of repeatedly seeing the same events over
and over again, sci-fi fans will love revisiting
a gem like this day after day after day.
"Find me when you wake up."
"What?"
"Come find me when you wa —"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!